a 13 year old boy faces a felony charge
in Illinois for recording a conversation
with his school principals without their
consent his state has one of the
strictest eavesdropping laws in the
country we're not revealing the boys
name because of his age he says he
recorded the conversation when he was
asked to explain why he wasn't showing
up for detention
that wasn't like high protection because
they're adults and it's usually their
word against mine when it's a child's
word against an adult's word and there's
no actual evidence of what was being
said the adult is gonna be taken into
account as the person being truthful
automatically and that automatically
renders the child totally voiceless
there's nothing there to protect the
children we asked the principal
assistant principal and school
superintendent for comment and have not
received a response the superintendent
told the Illinois Policy Institute they
cannot comment on a pending matter and
are not authorized to release
confidential student information CBS
News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman joins
us now Ricky the law is pretty strict
you can't record a conversation without
the consent of the other person so what
maybe the teens defense he has a good
defense and it's a factual defense about
what is a reasonable expectation of
privacy according to historians have
been reported he was called to the
principal's office he was talking with
the principal assistant principal but in
the reception area where the secretary
would ordinarily sit with an open door
so there's a question of whether you
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
in a reception area and where people
could walk by in addition this was a
conversation about discipline so wasn't
it logical that the boy would go home
and tell his parents and that the school
disciplinary ins would tell his parents
so is there reasonable expected he
recorded what was the content of the
country why did he feel the need to
record well he felt the need to record
it according to he and his mother
because he had felt that the school was
not treating him appropriately and
therefore he wanted a record of it so as
soon as he tells them that he's recorded
it they stopped the conversation
abruptly and then two months later he
finds out he's charged with the class
for felony and what does that mean class
four felony if I'm 13 in my face and
hard what am I facing no you were not
facing hard it's it's we can laugh about
it and I originally thought oh this will
blow over then I found out you know in
Illinois it's an overzealous prosecution
by many about this particular statute so
what does he really face he faces being
adjudicated a delinquent as a juvenile
which mean he could go 4 which means
that he could go from being supervised
or he could go to a juvenile detention
center and he could be held in a
juvenile detention center though I don't
anticipate it till the age of 21 in
addition to that as we all might have
thought if you have a juvenile
adjudication you think that your record
no one can see I would have certainly
thought that but it turns out that in
certain instances prospective employers
and colleges can get a hold of a
juvenile adjudication of delinquency
that to me was pretty stunning and so
there are collateral consequences this
is a kid who was interested perhaps in
having a career in the military well
that's a problem for him and a class 4
felony if you were an adult
for heaven's sake 1 2 3 years in prison
and a $25,000 fine it's no laughing
matter well now I know what I know is I
really want to hear the tape but we
asked the state's attorney who said he
can't comment on a pending juvenile
matter but he did say this when his
office gets a case that meets the
requirements for charges and can be
proven beyond a reasonable doubt they
file it so is he just doing his job it
seems very extreme if this seems very
extreme do you want me to just become a
rocket ship going out of my chair what
happened to pricing today not today what
happened to prosecutorial discretion we
know the prosecutorial discretion exists
throughout this country and that a lead
prosecutor or even a lying prosecutor
when I was a young assistant I could go
to my boss the DA and say do we really
want to prosecute this guy Manresa I
mean hey wait a minute you know let's
look we're an hour outside of Chicago
why are we prosecuting this 13 year old
as if this were a gun crime considering
all that's going on in Chicago thank you
a week or something always good to have
you here at the table